some good news mandalay bay park mgm and
the mirage all resume around the clock
operations starting
today each property has had some form of
midweek shutdown for the past
several months because of low demand the
head of mgm resorts cited decreasing
coven numbers
and positive growth in travel for this
decision ceo bill hornbuckle
said he is optimistic about recovery
here in las vegas
and getting more and more employees back
to work in less than two weeks now
businesses can operate at 50
capacity here in las vegas local
economic analyst jeremy aguero says many
signs are pointing to a great spring and
summer for las vegas
right now it's very different we're
talking about hotels coming back online
going 24
7. we're talking about restaurants
opening back up we're even talking about
seeing people
hiring additional folks when we weren't
having that conversation at all
three months ago i think that trend is
remarkably positive
good news he says las vegas is still
only halfway through an
18 to 36 month recovery process though
and he says proposed increased
unemployment benefits and stimulus
checks
should help float our recovery through
summer then things like conventions and
sporting events could return john